I try to recreate my grandma's favorite
vacation I'm Oscar and this is my
grandma Maria she's picked this vacation
that she wants me to take I'm excited to
find out what it is she's been to so
many different places and she's not
scared of anything that's for sure yeah
I don't travel that much because I am
always working she's saying to forget
that you have a phone just like you
forget that you have a grandma sometimes
I definitely need to unplug from work to
just go Aska I want you create my
vacation do you going through how why
I'm gonna have why y'all I've never been
to Hawaii I'm gonna try my best to
recreate her vacation but also put my
own spin on it we're about to board our
flight are you excited I'm excited we're
going to a ye
[Music]
so it's day one and I haven't checked my
phone yet I haven't checked any emails
which is good so I'm kind of hoping I
can do that the rest of the week we're
staying at the Travis uh experiential
resort a spectacular just views for days
[Music]
so I'm gonna go on the Expedia app and
find things to do I think I need to call
my grandma and ask her opinion hi
grandma I'm here in Hawaii
I got her safely was trying to book a
fun tour or fun activity parasailing
ziplining which do you recommend
all right kids I go India bye grandma
love you buckle up parasailing
[Music]
literally the best it was great it was a
jam-packed day but I just felt very
relaxed worried didn't even come to mind
unplugging from live responsibilities
even for a couple of hours it changes
your mindset perfect but may making it's
about nurturing your thoughts it's about
honoring its people and its culture 190
beautiful the you know if my grandma
she's very also giving and nurturing and
caring which is what the hawaiian
culture is and what i learned one of the
fun moments that jr. and i did was we
created so my grandma's Maui photos my
favorite photo that we created is her in
front of the pool at the resort if she
was saying that it was cool just kind of
like oh this is Rebecca legit and she
put a lot of effort into her photos so
let me do the same to you know kind of
share something with her that she would
appreciate definitely something that I'm
always gonna remember going back home
I'm definitely gonna implement mana
which means using your inner strength
I'm gonna definitely put myself in
situations that I'm not used to and jump
out of my box and just do it I think I
succeeded in recreating my grandma's
vacation when it comes to the culture
and getting to know people around here
being on this trip and not having to
check any work emails and actually
allowing myself to not look at my phone
has definitely been like a recharge a
rebirth you know what just let it be
you'll be fine one of the biggest
realizations that I've had is just
wanting to travel more and experience so
many other places that I want to go to
this has been one of the most
eye-opening and freeing experiences that
I've ever had
[Music]